durante los dos próximos meses la
esperanza del cese de los bombardeos en
yemen justo antes del comienzo del mes
de ramadán la onu consiguió que ambas
partes se pongan de acuerdo los rebeldes
huthi y las fuerzas yemeníes respaldadas
por arabia saudita han acordado un alto
el fuego las partes acordaron detener
las ofensivas militares a nivel nacional
por tierra mar y aire también se
pusieron de acuerdo para dejar entrar a
los barcos de combustible en el puerto
dejó de ida y reanudar los vuelos
comerciales desde el aeropuerto de saná
guard la capital sanaá está en manos de
los rebeldes huthi y el puerto de judá y
da también por aquí pasa la mayor parte
de la ayuda humanitaria
la guerra ha provocado el colapso de la
economía en esta nación árabe y ahora el
80 por ciento de la población depende de
la ayuda internacional para sobrevivir
en 2016 los rebeldes huthi y las fuerzas
gubernamentales ya habían acordado una
tregua nacional pero ésta no se mantuvo
con este nuevo acuerdo las naciones
unidas- esperan poner al país en el
camino de la recuperación
en esta tregua que tiene la posibilidad
de renovar coincide con el inicio del
mes sagrado de ramadán brasilia - abre
la puerta a abordar las urgentes
necesidades humanitarias económicas de
yemen y a reiniciar un proceso político
en el país os debe ser un primer paso
para poner fin a esta devastadora en
yemen se cerró state in world hace meses
que la onu intenta conseguir un alto el
fuego en yemen desde julio de 2014 la
guerra se cobró la vida de más de 380
mil personas y provocó el desplazamiento
de millones